how the [ __ ] do you write so many books  so fast  I think I've had a really good six  months I've written three chapters and  you've you've finished three books in  that time here's the thing okay there  are there are books and there are books  the way that I work I try to get out  there and I try to get six pages a day  when I'm working I work every day three  four hours and I try to get those six  pages and I try to get them fairly clean  so if the manuscript is let's say 360  pages long that's basically two months  work it's concentrated but it's a fairly  but that's assuming that it goes well  and you do hit six pages a day I usually  do you don't ever have a day where you  sit down there and it's like  constipation and you write a sentence  and you hate the sentence and okay you  you check your email and you wonder if  you had any Talent after all and maybe  you should have been a plumber